(light music)
- One of things that
I need to expand on
in a 2017 marketing conversation
is the variable of
Facebook creative in it's ROI.
Something that is I'm tapping
into is that 90% of digital
execution is garbage and so
I think a lot of people hear me
talk and they don't hear that
I say do Super Bowl because
I think it's
underpriced attention.
I think they don't hear me say
do live read iHeartRadio 'cause
radio's underpriced and
I think what they do here is
that Facebook is
magically gonna work
'cause it's
underpriced attention.
That is true.
Facebook will give you the best
at-bat in my opinion to hit all
Americans at the best price.
The problem is the creative.
If it's a shitty
kind of blurry picture,
if it's a
picture from a print ad,
if it's a video that use as a
pre-roll advertising or a video
that was actually
your TV commercial,
you're gonna lose 'cause
the creative is the variable.
Once you have my attention,
you've gotta get me excited to
buy your thing and we have not
had enough conversation in the
marketplace around the
modern Facebook commercial.
This 1, 2, 3,
4, 5 minute video
that is a story,
that is compelling people to
get excited about a product or
service or mission.
And I feel like I've even
been too general and I will push
harder, much harder to make
sure that people recognize how
important that
creative is and that's when,
you know I just read Chipotle
is spending more
money on television.
I'm just sitting here saying
okay they definitely could've
done better if they put all
that media money into Facebook.
I just generally believe that
but I was like but why would
television work better than
Facebook if that was a bake-off
and the answer is even
though it'd be still gonna be a
crappy 30-second commercial,
it is absolutely true that they
could've made a very
crappy, even crappier,
even crappier commercial video
on Facebook and then that would
be the reason that television
could outperform Facebook in a
here's $4 million,
here's $4 million bake-off.
The creative is the variable and
that debate and our attention to
the good creative and the
great videos that drive business
results needs to absolutely
happen for marketers big and
small to be successful
in the new environment.
(hip hop music)